dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here today we
are going to talk about planet a
technique that is meant to solve
challenging image based planning tasks
with sparse rewards okay that sounds
great but what do all of these terms
mean the planning part is simple it
means that the AI has to come up with a
sequence of actions to achieve a goal
like pole balancing with a cart teaching
a virtual human or cheetah to walk or
hitting this box the right way to make
sure it keeps rotating the image based
part is big this means that the AI has
to learn the same way as a human and
that is by looking at the pixels of the
images this is a huge difficulty bump
because the AI does not only have to
learn to defeat the game itself but also
has to build an understanding of the
visual concepts within the game deep
minds legendary deep cue learning
algorithm was able to learn from pixel
inputs but it was mighty inefficient at
doing that and no wonder this problem
formulation is immensely hard and it is
a miracle that we can master any
solution at all that can figure it out
the sparse reward part means that we
rarely get feedback as to how well we
are doing at these tasks which is a
nightmare situation for any learning
algorithm the key difference with this
technique against classical
reinforcement learning which is what
most researchers reach out to to solve
similar tasks is that this one uses
models for the planning this means that
it does not learn every new task from
scratch but after the first game
whichever it may be it will have a
rudimentary understanding of gravity and
dynamics and it will be able to reuse
this knowledge in the next games as a
result it will get a head start when
learning a new game and is therefore
often 50 times more efficient than the
previous technique that learns from
scratch and not only that but it has
other really cool advantages as well
which I will tell you about in just a
moment here you can see that indeed the
blue lines significantly outperform the
previous techniques shown with red and
green for each of these tasks I like how
the plot is organ
in the same grid as the tasks were and
it makes it much more readable when
juxtaposed with the video footage as
promised here are the two really cool
additional advantages of this
model-based agent the first is that we
don't have to train six separate AIS for
all of these tasks but finally we can
get one AAA that is able to solve all
six of these tasks efficiently and
second it can look at as little as five
frames of an animation which is
approximately one-fifth of a second
worth of footage that is barely anything
and it is able to predict how the
sequence would continue with a
remarkably high accuracy and over a long
time frame which is quite a challenge
this is an excellent paper with
beautiful mathematical formulations I
recommend that you have a look in the
video description the source code is
also available free of charge for
everyone so I bet this will be an
exciting direction for future research
works and I'll be here to report on it
to you make sure to subscribe and hit
the bell icon to not miss future
episodes thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time